we now know what an oxidation state or
an oxidation number is and what it means
when things are oxidized or reduced and
let's see how that actually happens in
reactions so we're going to study in
this video is oxidation
oxidation slash reduction reactions and
all that is is a reaction where
somebody's being oxidized which means
that electrons are being taken away from
them and someone's being reduced which
means that they're being handed
electrons or they're taking electrons
away from someone else and sometimes
this has been termed because you have
the the red and reduction and you have
the oxygen oxidation and they switch
them around and they call this a redox
reaction which sounds like a very fancy
chemistry term but it just means a
reaction where something is getting
oxidized and if something is getting
oxidized something else is getting
reduced so let's study a couple of them
so right here i actually have combustion
this is actually methane so you know
methane is a fuel it can be used to you
can make a motor powered on methane
right there it's a hydrocarbon most
fuels that we use are hydrocarbons which
just mean carbons bonded in a bunch of
different ways to a bunch of hydrogens
and if you add a bunch enough heat for
the reaction to happen so it's
activation energy you have to put it in
there with some oxygen around it's going
to combust and it's going to produce
carbon dioxide and water and i didn't
put it here and even more heat than you
put into it so it's actually an
exothermic reaction it produces more
heat than you put into it and i'll do a
lot more of that in future videos on
endothermic and exothermic reactions but
anyway we care about the oxidation and
the reduction so let's see if anyone's
getting oxidized or anyone is getting
reduced here
so let's look at their oxidation numbers
or their states
here carbon is bonded to four hydrogens
who's giving who's taking
so carbon let's go to our periodic table
carbon is here
hydrogen is here
carbon is more electronegative it's
almost it's it's adjacent to kind of the
the three musketeers of
electronegativity these guys are the
most electronegative we always ignore
the halogens because they pretty much
not the halogen sorry the noble gases
because they pretty much don't react at
all they're always happy with their
eight valence electrons these guys love
to get electrons they're small molecules
their outermost shell is close to the
pro is close to the nucleus and they're
so close to becoming noble that they
just they they just love hogging
electrons carbon's almost there carbon's
much further right on the periodic table
than the hydrogen so if you if you have
carbon bonding with hydrogen carbon is
going to be the electron hog
so in this situation
let's go down here
so if carbon's the electron hog and
hydrogen is having its electrons taken
away from it
remember this is all kind of
hypothetical it's more partial is the
reality but in if if you had to pick or
choose hydrogen is going to lose
electron each
so it's going to have an oxidation state
of plus one for each hydrogen you have
four hydrogens each giving up an
electron so the
carbon must be taking four electrons
so its oxidation number is minus four
it's taken four electrons so its charge
will go down by four so that's why it's
negative fair enough what's the
oxidation state of this oxygen right
there let's just bond it to itself
there's no reason to believe that one
oxygen should be able to take any
electrons from another oxygen so it has
a
zero oxidation state
it's not hogging more than its its fair
share of electrons that it was
essentially kind of born with now after
the combustion occurs
what are the oxidation numbers
well i have oxygen bonded with carbon
two oxygens bonded with carbon
now we know oxygen i mean oxidation was
to some degree named after oxygen it is
one of the most electronegative almost
anything bonded with oxygen is going to
be giving up its electrons we also know
that oxygen likes to take two electrons
because if it takes one two electrons
then it starts having a if it takes one
it gets here two it gets here it has a
configuration like it has eight valence
electrons so its typical oxidation
number is minus two
so
carbon in this in this situation your
each oxygen is going to have a minus
two oxidation number the carbon dioxide
molecule
is neutral so everything has to add up
to zero the oxygens you have two of them
each of them with a minus two oxidation
number so that's minus four so carbon
must be plus four
plus 4
which means that it has given up 4
electrons
right and really it only has 4 electrons
to give up it has 1 2
3 4
valence electrons and it's in its second
shell which is its reactive shell so
it's oxidation numbers plus four now
let's look at the water we've done that
a bunch when the the hydrogens each give
up an electron so they get they have an
oxidation number of one
each oxygen takes two electrons there's
only one of them so it's minus two
so what's going on here
what's getting oxidized what's getting
reduced you have the carbon it went from
an oxidation number of minus four to an
oxidation number of
plus four
so let me just draw what's happening to
the carbon
carbon goes from minus four which means
it's hogging four electrons
to
a situation where it's where it's having
four electrons being hogged from it it's
kind of giving away four electrons so
someplace in this process
this guy must have given away
eight electrons this is a difference of
eight electrons so plus
plus
eight electrons so what's happened to
carbon
carbon has been
has it been oxidized or reduced
its charge has gone up so it hasn't been
reduced or the other way is that you can
say it's electrons have been taken away
from it so it has been oxidized
oxidized carbon has
oxidized
now let's look at
the oxygen itself
oxygen over here you have
four oxygen molecules i'll just write
four oxygen molecules here
and they all have an oxidation state of
zero they have their from an oxidation
number point of view they're neutral and
on this side we have two and then we
have four four oxygen molecules
and what's their oxidation state
they're all minus two
so oxygen must each of these oxygens
must have gained an electron so actually
let me let me rewrite this reaction
let me rewrite let me erase a little bit
of it
so each of these are actually even
better let me just move this over
nope
let me move it over there you go and i
can move that over
there you go and let me fill in that
just so we aesthetically it's pleasing
there you go
all right
so we have four oxygens with a zero
oxidation state turning into four
oxygens with a minus two oxidation state
so each of these four oxygens took
two electrons there's four of them so we
must have
we must have gained
eight electrons
so what happened to oxygen its oxidation
state went down or its hypothetical
charge went down or it was reduced its
charge was reduced so this is
reduced
oxygen was reduced
what was it reduced by it was reduced by
by the carbon
what was the carbon oxidized by it was
oxidized
by the oxygen which oxygen tends to do
it tends to oxidize things what is the
oxidizing agent what's the thing that
did the oxidizing
so
the oxygen is the oxidizing
agent
what is the reducing agent what's the
thing that did the reducing it's the
reducing agent is the carbon
reducing agent so you see in this redox
reaction carbon was oxidized it gave
away eight electrons from this state to
that state hypothetically and oxygen was
reduced its charge was reduced by a
total of eight electrons but for two for
each oxygen and so its oxidation number
went down let's do a couple more and
each of these things i wrote just to
kind of do a side note this is called a
half reaction because i'm writing just
what happened to the carbon and here i'm
writing just what happened to the oxygen
and i did ignore something i did ignore
the hydrogen and i encourage you to do
something like this with a hydrogen but
you'll see that hydrogen was neither
oxidized or reduced on both sides of
this equation all of the hydrogens had a
plus one oxidation state
let's do another one
here i have another combustion situation
this is what happened to the hindenburg
they filled a balloon full with hydrogen
because they wanted it to float because
hydrogen is is a very light gas
unfortunately there must have been a
spark and uh in the presence of oxygen
and it combusted
and actually this is you this is what is
used for a rocket fuel as well if you
have liquid hydrogen and uh actually i
don't think they have liquid well i
don't know enough about rocket science
i'll have to do another video on that in
the future but let's look at the
oxidation states what's the oxidation
state of hydrogen here in its elemental
form it's zero two hydrogens bonded to
each other no reason why they should hog
or or be hogged by another hydrogen
two oxygen molecules are atoms bonded to
each other once again zero oxidation
state
once they combust and form water what's
their oxidation states we've done this
multiple times the oxygen has a minus
two oxidation state each hydrogen
has a plus one so let's write the half
reactions
we have two
hydrogens
that are just happy as they are neutral
state and they end up
being
sorry yeah same thing two h2s or we
could have written four hydrogens either
way they turn into two hydrogens two
hydrogen molecules there's actually four
hydrogen atoms with a plus one oxidation
state
so they must have each given away one
electron now how many total hydrogens
are there there are four so we must have
given away four electrons plus four
electrons so this is a half reaction for
hydrogen
now let's do the same thing for our
oxygen
we have
some oxygen here
on the left hand side it has
a neutral oxidation state
and then it
ends up with a
we end up with two oxygens on the right
hand side i could write it well i'll
write it like this 2o
each with a minus 2 oxidation state so
each of these oxygens must have gotten
two electrons
so it got
two electrons each or it gained four
electrons so what was oxidized oxidized
means that something was taken electrons
were taken away from you the hydrogen
was oxidized this is
oxidized
by oxygen
what was reduced
the oxygen was reduced
by
by the hydrogen
and if you actually add these two
reactions up if you make this the
left-hand side of your equation
and you make this the right-hand side of
your equation
that you could say okay let's remove the
electrons from both sides and you'll end
up with your original reaction what was
and just to make sure our terminology is
right what's our oxidizing agent is the
thing doing the oxidizing is the oxygen
what's our reducing agent it's the
hydrogen let's do one more
so here i have iron plus some
hydrochloric acid let's say this is an
aqueous solution and you end up with
iron ii chloride plus some hydrogen so
let's do some oxidation numbers and i'll
do it fast this time
iron is just by itself it's got a zero
oxidation state
hydrogen with chloride chloride is a
halogen halogen these guys love to take
electrons they love to take one electron
they typically have a minus one
oxidation state
so this the chlorine is going to have
minus one
the hydrogen is going to be plus one
add them together you get to a neutral
compound fair enough
now you go on this side
what is chlorine's oxidation state well
once again it always likes to take one
electron so this is minus one but i have
two chlorines here
this is a neutral compound
so the iron oxidation state must be plus
two
plus two what about the hydrogen now
it's just in its elemental form so it's
going to be neutral so it has a zero
oxidation state
so what was oxidized
our iron
our iron went from neutral
to being
to having two electrons taken away from
it which may give it a positive charge
so so plus two electrons got taken away
so this was oxidized
so this is oxidized
what about the hydrogen
the hydrogen went from
two hydrogens with a plus one
state
and essentially they went two way
to two hydrogens with a neutral state so
two electrons must have been added to
the hydrogens
two electrons were added their charge
was reduced so they were reduced
and what were they reduced by they were
reduced by the iron what was the iron
oxidized by it was oxidized by the
hydrogen what about the chlorine the
chlorine has a minus one oxidation
number here it has a minus one oxidation
number here it was it was neutral
relative to the redox reaction anyway i
think you get the point now and you
could do this with a bunch of reactions
but this will give you a little bit more
insight of actually what's going on and
who's gaining or losing electrons and in
the future it'll also help us think
about a lot of the structures of
molecules anyway see in the next video